[Music]
over the last decades and with the
arrival of blockchain
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin have
capsized the economic world
by giving individuals the power to
interact with each other without any
third party involved
neutralizing the role of official
institutions such as Banks authorities
and other state institutions
is it really as some say that blockchain
will be the end of the state in its
current form
does this mean we are freed from
institutions
or will we still be governed by
institutions of another kind
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
once we got stuck in the desert right
before sunset
the car wouldn't start
we had no mechanic
so we had to use the knowledge each of
us had
and building on one suggestion and
expertise after the other
we could finally solve the problem and
get to safety
alone I couldn't have done that
but collectively we could and we made it
without needing a mechanic
[Music]
this always made me think of the power
of a group of people focusing on solving
a problem
it is just amazing how much more we can
achieve together
if we can connect what everyone knows
now that we have the technology to
connect globally
I wonder about what we could achieve
together
how powerful could we be
I wonder
how strong we could become
the individual who now has a lot more
power to decide how they want to
economically interact with other people
by 2030 4 billion people in this planet
will use cryptocurrencies on a daily
basis
there are people who claim that
blockchain is a gateway to an inevitable
Revolution a revolution that threatens
the survival of State institutions
and may threaten the survival of the
state itself
is blockchain that dangerous
and I wonder what the future will be
like if chain fulfilled all its promises
[Music]
sometimes I feel that we've built a
gigantic world where people mean nothing
compared to the size and power of an
institution
experts say it's been going on forever
since we needed a middleman someone to
receive the transactions and set the
rules of the game
we gave power to all kinds of
Institutions from governments to Banks
and we also gave them the right to keep
this power
even by force of violence
[Music]
[Applause]
now they say this will change
that we need middlemen less and less
thanks to blockchain
[Music]
but first I'd like to understand what
blockchain really means
and what its real potential is
Jameson Lop uses his skills as a
technologist to build tools that Empower
individuals I'm lucky he's agreed to
speak
hi Jameson how are you doing I am doing
well glad to be here can you explain to
me what exactly is blockchain
so from a technical standpoint a
blockchain is just a data structure it's
a new type of database you can think of
it as a new way of storing historical
data that has built-in Integrity checks
how is blockchain connected to the
internet Revolution and what kind of
change does it bring with it it really
of course taken away the concentration
of power of you know who can control
communication and narratives and it
really it has turned the individual
into someone who now has a lot more
power to decide how the information gets
shared and how they want to economically
interact with other people you know this
is what we call you appear to peer and
basically it means that you now are much
more connected to everyone else in the
world you don't necessarily have to go
through third parties because you're
just doing it directly with whoever you
want to interact with
how does blockchain facilitate
peer-to-peer transactions
because you're no longer having to trust
a third party to maintain the Integrity
of that database and to trust that they
are not tampering with it now everyone
can download it and can read it and can
audit it and you know this creates a
whole new trust model for data do you
think blockchain is rewriting economic
power well yes so so now people are
talking about the metaverse and they're
talking about you know essentially
buying like these decentralized land
Properties or or objects or nfts that
will work in the metaverse the problem
is like we don't know what platform is
going to end up being the major Network
because these things all have Network
effects and there's going to be one
dominant one and then probably a lot of
other smaller ones but most of the value
is going to accrue in one dominant one
and I just hope that it's not Facebook
because I don't want it you know a
centralized corporate surveillance type
of virtual reality setup
[Music]
it's an attractive idea
that the basis for future interaction
will be voluntary horizontal and secure
and privacy is important A Whole New
World in which we are taking charge
but are we really able to replace the
institutions that manage transactions
between people
there are people who say that we are
able and that we have already begun to
liberate ourselves from the
establishment's control and that the
revolution has begun and their example
is digital currencies which is one of
the applications of blockchain
there are people today
who are able to live their lives
normally without having to deal with
banks which are controlled by a complex
capitalist banking system and without
needing to deal with traditional money
a price and issuance of which are
controlled by countries
all this through digital currencies
Matthew vanierkerk a business Pioneer
and an expert in financial technology
which tell me about cryptocurrencies and
about the revolution against the
traditional banking system
hi Matthew thank you for making the time
yeah hi Amber it's a pleasure to be here
I have a few questions for you
what are cryptocurrencies and how do
they work so it essentially it's the
same as cash as we know today
um and it has the properties of being
able to exchange peer-to-peer so I can
engage in in transactions in a
peer-to-peer way without
requiring the involvement of banks or or
other intermediaries to to guide
transactions in the process how do you
imagine the future with blockchain
um so it's it's early days there's a lot
of adoption to come ahead but I do
believe that by yeah 2030 4 billion
people in this planet will use
cryptocurrencies on it on a daily basis
um and by then maybe not just on this
planet maybe on Mars as well we'll see
what would happen to all middlemen
do you really believe they will all
disappear I think that for society to
operate there's still a rule for some
intermediaries to be involved no I don't
think that blockchain will completely
remove intermediaries
um there's still
um what what a lot of intermediaries
that we work with today in society I
think become Gatekeepers in a way so
there's there's a role in some form of
gatekeeping to make sure that
information
that's put on chain is legitimate there
is still a rule to be played there
according to Matthew
blockchain would need what they call
Gatekeepers
but who are The Gatekeepers that Matthew
is talking about
from what I understood they are the
technology companies that manage our
presence in the virtual world
and they are the companies that will
have to deal with our profiles in the
digital identification space
does this mean we are replacing one
broker with another
are we witnessing a revolution to
liberate us from the institution
or a revolution in which we replaced the
ruling class with another
like so many revolutions
[Music]
or is it just a transitional phase
as many say towards the real empowerment
of the individual
[Music]
can you imagine the kind of power we
could reach if everyone collaborated
without an intermediary without a
middleman
are you serious
did you not hear the man say that the
big tech companies are going to be the
middlemen so what
it means that we are Arabs and in all
those big tech companies there isn't one
that is Arab are you okay with getting
governed by Mark Zuckerberg and Google
foreign
I want to look in more detail at
blockchain and the decentralization of
Institutions from an Arab perspective
the Qatari entrepreneur Muhammad
al-jafari
has been an established life coach and
business Mentor for well over a decade
I would like to ask him about the lack
of relevant Arab Tech Platforms in the
field
and how this can be shifted in the
future
is
[Music]
um
foreign
uh
um
foreign
[Music]
we had built a gigantic world where
people meant little
chain brings a new beginning
we can choose to build a world for the
people
whether this brand new world is also
fairer and more egalitarian
will be for us the individuals to tight
[Music]
thank you
foreign